sans on passe à notre dernier sujet il
nous reste quelques minutes pour parler
de la sphère rigaud qui a engendré ce
matin une passe d'armes entre le
ministre de l'intérieur et olivier faure
il faut rembobinez ce matin sur france
inter
christophe castaner était interrogé sur
les propos du premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste qui hier avait pointé
du doigt la légèreté coupable de
benjamin griveaux à propos de sa fameuse
vidéo
et voici donc la réponse du ministre de
l'intérieur
j'avais comme tout est mis sur la place
publique ça appelle effectivement à
minima à cette prudence
ensuite vous savez les hommes politiques
la femme politique qu'il faut qu'il
reste des femmes et des hommes parce que
sinon ils sont aussi coupés de la
réalité vous savez il nous nous sommes
des femmes et des hommes et faut pas
prétendre qu'on soit des super héros et
moi j'invite la classe politique a
beaucoup de modestie j'ai été surpris
d'entendre
olivier faur ici dans votre micro je
connais bien olivier faur à titre
personnel depuis longtemps je
l'accompagné dans ses dimensions ces
séparations et c'est vrai que j'ai
entendues ont été assez étonné ses
leçons de morale et la réplique
d'olivier fort ne s'est pas fait
attendre c'était il ya une heure ce
matin une ligne rouge a été franchie le
fait pour un ministre de l'intérieur de
chercher à intimider
l'un des dirigeants de l'opposition en
ayant recours à des insinuations
relevant de sa vie privée et d'une
atteinte au fondement même de la
démocratie
et soyons tout à fait complet christophe
castaner vient de tweeter il n'y avait
ni menace ni attaques personnelles dans
mon propos nous nous connaissons depuis
assez longtemps pour savoir l'un et
l'autre que la vie n'est pas linéaire
nous y avons quelquefois fait face
ensemble
lucile schmid c'était effectivement pas
très élégant de la part de christophe
castaner oui ça vous inspire
est-ce que ça m'inspire c'est que
olivier faur effectivement disait
benjamin griveaux avait été imprudent
politiquement là bas il parlait pas du
contenu la sextape
ensuite je trouve que le fait que les
efforts répondent en parlant de lui même
à la troisième
troisième personne on a voulu intimider
un leader de l'opposition est tout aussi
ridicule
et ensuite que l'autre répond dans dix
ans mais on se connaît bien on est potes
est tout aussi ridicule
je pense que quelque part ça traduit le
fait que nous sommes dans un microcosme
français et qu'on aurait envie d'élargir
le recrutement des élites politiques pas
les ailiers d'ailleurs qu'on aurait
envie que chacun ait envie de faire de
la politique et qu'on se connaisse pas
depuis 25 ans et qu'on n'ait pas fait
tous les camps voilà ce que sam aspire
par ailleurs j'espère effectivement
qu'on peut continuer à divorcer
librement en france sans que ça fasse
l'objet d'un élément de réputation
politique mais en fait ça me laisse
perplexe je je je crois qu'il faut
qu'ils arrêtent et surtout olivier faur
qu'il arrête de parler de lui même à la
troisième personne
ça c'est nicolas baverez vous êtes
perplexe aussi n'ont pas perplexe c'est
accablant donc c'est la vieille formule
visé basse et viser juste c'est vrai que
ça n'a plus rien à voir avec de la
politique
celui qui est le plus coupable est
évidemment christophe castaner parce
qu'il est censé avoir la responsabilité
d'un ministère qui est quand même assez
important pour la vie quotidienne de nos
concitoyens
on est dans un moment où la violence
explose ou ça contribue à la poussée de
l'extrême droite
et donc ils feraient mieux de s'occuper
de diriger son ministère de s'occuper de
la sécurité des français plus que
effectivement de la sécurité
psychologique des dirigeants de
l'opposition de quoi que ce soit donc
c'est très triste ça montre la faiblesse
aussi de ce qu'est devenue la classe
politique aujourd'hui dans notre pays et
on a envie de dire je pense que les
citoyens une fois de plus sont plus
responsables que leurs dirigeants
aujourd'hui est que le citoyen sont
légitimement même pas écoeurer mémé tu
peux faire est interdit devant la
nullité de ces échanges est que les
dirigeants devraient un peu se reprendre
et être un peu plus digne des fonctions
qu'ils occupent tous que ce soit dans un
gouvernement où d'ailleurs dans
l'opposition un internaute qui nous
regardent nous demande
je suppose avec ironie qui est olivier
faure qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
d'abord christophe castaner a raison sur
un point quand il dit les français ne
croient pas que les politiques sont des
super héros je confirme personne ne
pense qu'il est un super héros de ce
point de vue là ça me paraît très clair
ensuite il a quand même un problème
christophe cartin castaner sérieux si
derrière cette histoire benjamin
griveaux il s'avérait qu'il y aurait une
forme de complot et ses possibles
semble-t-il qu'il ya eu une vraie
manipulation une vraie
instrumentalisation d'une vidéo
évidemment diffusé de manière absolument
stupide c'est pas ça qui est en jeu
c'est l'idée qu'il y est un complot et
si son ministère ne l'a pas vu et si son
ministère n'a pas été capable de le
prévenir
alors là il y a un vrai problème de
compétence donc de ce point de vue très
franchement aller dire ce qu'il a dit à
olivier faure
ça n'a aucun sens le vrai sujet c'est
est ce que le ministère de l'intérieur
aujourd'hui a les moyens d'empêcher que
cette politique qui est plus qu'une
politique des boules puantes ce cette
espèce de deux cancers ou 7 propres
possibilités d'un cancer à base de
rumeurs de sextape et hot que ça se
protège et que ça déstabilise tout le
monde parce que ça c'est un danger non
pas pour le parti au pouvoir mais pour
la démocratie tout simplement
nicole nous dit castaner a tout loupé
depuis qu'il est en fonction il insiste
dans la bêtise
alexandre de victimes dernière réaction
non juste moi je vous crois pas du tout
à la théorie du complot mais je crois à
l'amateurisme généralisée d'ailleurs
c'est ce qui ce qui est énervant dans
cette histoire c'est que castanet la
criée la démocratie la vie privée c'est
très important et qui paf et refait
exactement la même chose c'est pas la
première fois je rappelle qu'il a été
condamné quand il était adjoint au maire
d'avignon pour diffuser une bd
pornographiques sur sa sur sa
concurrente dont 15 me
manifestement il ya un côté arroseur
arrosé dans tout ça effectivement le
problème c'est un problème de niveau on
a beaucoup parlé samedi un vrai
vaudeville ses gouvernants oui c'est ça
mais on a ce qu'on pense qu'on a
beaucoup parlé des vopos pu laisser on
peut être choquée par la vulgarité de
donald trump parfois ou d'autres mais
quand on voit le niveau de la classe
politique française il faut pas
s'étonner effectivement de la fracture
entre les élites et le peuple et nous
terminerons cette émission avec une
phrase sage de roulement qui nous dit
combats de coqs kouba pas grand chose de
pertinent à la fin la réplique de
christophe castaner sur la vie privée
d'olivier fort et elle indécente vous
êtes une grande majorité à nous dire que
oui merci infiniment de nous avoir suivi
on se retrouve demain dans point de vue
à la même heure avec laurence de
charette
[Musique]